oh yeah so you're doing a lot of stuff
now do you tend to do a lot of stuff
because
you really love doing it you want to do
it or do you think there's part of it
that you want to prove yourself
100 both 100 percent both yeah as a
woman
um i've been acting since i was 12.
i've always been an actress i don't
think i'm a stellar actress
i think i'm a working actor and so i
want to show that i can do other things
so there's definitely a prove yourself
part to writing and directing and i've
been producing but also i really enjoyed
it like i enjoy
i enjoy the control um my soul to take
looks beautiful i had crew from like
i'll send you a link from canada my
composer was stellar like it was a lot
of women
um but you just said something a few
minutes ago
you said i don't think of myself as a
stellar actress is that true
do you look at yourself and say i know
what i'm good at i think i'm good
you think you're good i think i'm good
do you know you're good and i'm getting
better yeah
yeah i i but you don't think you're
great you don't think you're stellar
no i think i'm i'm i'm good that's hard
to say it's hard to
somebody said are you a great actor i'm
not gonna compare myself
to you know meryl streep i think i'm a
working actor who can do a good job
right you know that's why i get cast in
and shows that i do
because i i can bring it and and leave
and
you know like handmaids i
haven't seen that yet but i hear that
you have it's a fantastic role
i mean for for handmaids i i booked it
i had to do three auditions
and i was two days out from my
days on starting my days on set pandemic
hit i waited seven months with all those
scenes in my head with elizabeth
freaking the [ __ ] out for seven seven
months running torturing yourself
yeah yeah and then you killed it that's
what i'm hearing but
um i was petrified i watched it i
i can't watch but you watched yourself
in handmaids i can't watch all of it i
just
how are you how did you like yourself i
thought i
did a good job
but i was elizabeth i was terrified
you know what i'm getting on a head show
see i never understood that like guest
stars
that is the hardest [ __ ] thing i've
never had to really experience that
you're the new kid in school i i don't
know if i could deal with just coming on
a set and everybody's like
this [ __ ] i hope he's [ __ ] nose
lines i hope he's voting and i'm just
it's in my head i'm like [ __ ]
i just wanna you know what i mean and
then you have to just and action oh can
we replace him
is rosenbaum available
you